je pense qu'il est prudent de dire que les essais de labyrinthe
ont été un succès complet,
il est trop tôt pour le dire, mais ils pourraient être
la clé de tout,
il est temps maintenant de commencer la phase deux,
bienvenue dans la brûlure
du monde extérieur accroché par une très
mince menace
au-delà de cette porte  se trouve le début de
tes nouvelles vies
hé thomas nous n'étions pas le seul labyrinthe
que te souviens-tu de méchant je
me souviens qu'ils m'ont envoyé dans le labyrinthe
je me souviens avoir vu mes amis mourir
devant moi tu ne veux pas comprendre
comprendre quoi pourquoi  tout cela s'est passé
j'ai juste besoin de savoir de quel côté êtes-vous
ils cachent quelque chose allez vous
ne savez pas
qu'ils nous ont menti nous ne nous sommes jamais échappés
tout cela faisait partie de leur plan que
veulent-ils de nous
thomas le labyrinthe  est une chose dont les deux
enfants parlent le dernier jour dans la
torride,
quel diable
le cours de vos vies déterminera
le cours de l'humanité
dans la lumière ou l'obscurité
vous